so you're a Harvard guy yeah and McLovin
is Dartmouth guy didn't get into Harvard
no big deal I don't hold a grudge sounds
like it was the first thing on your mind
oh wait crushes him oh whatever if you
went to Stanford it that would be the
only thing would be worse if you went to
Stanford right Stanford that good but
I'm tryin think it will come back like
why a Stanford was not Ivy League I mean
we don't really consider that part of
the fraternity do we
okay so you're but you're using this
opportunity to badmouth Stanford yeah I
guess so
whatever how are the Winklevoss twins
Colin I think they're probably doing
pretty well they're definitely still
tall and desirable apparently and
millionaires yes multimillionaires I
rowed crew with them actually my
freshman year like and I I was a
heavyweight they made me they told me to
heavyweight which was crazy at the time
and these guys showed up and they were
they in my mind they were twice my
height the Winklevoss twins and i was
like how can i row against the
eventually I was lightweight but
originally it was like insane and then
they were doing they were they were so
good at rowing I was like there's no way
they created Facebook but did you know
but were you aware of Facebook and in
this whole yeah it was happening while I
was there and it was just but it was
just internal it was created as like the
way you would have an online your book
that's what they did that was the idea
of it and so it was just was the my
realistic school was the I asked they
have not seen a movie yet you have not
seen social I have not seen yet well you
got us really well done I know I know
I'm sure it's great I'm sure it's it's
great but I just haven't seen does
Zuckerberg know who you are I don't know
I mean we were there but everyone's
always like did you hang out and I say
no cuz I was writing comedy and he was
in a library creating Facebook you know
but have you reached out to maybe have
him host Saturday Night Live would that
that's interesting he hosts who's been
by actually I've met him at the show cuz
he's come by and hung out and stuff but
I don't know if he would ever remember
me from being there but where did you
take part in Facebook
while you were at Harvard definitely
definitely not on a financial but we're
reminded by my relatives but it was
basically just for Harvard and then it
became the Ivy League exactly yeah and
but it was at the time you didn't know
cuz there were so many things you know
MySpace there was there are even
individual ones that were started at
other colleges and kind of became that
and for some reason I mean he obviously
he made a lot of good business decisions
at every level that kept it growing but
at the time you didn't know what it was
you just thought it was like another web
you never knew websites were money you
know when you're at least at that age
maybe other people did he did in the
Winklevoss twins they did yeah yeah yeah
so I probably should have known
yeah well I have a lot of things but
okay so when you leave you leave Harvard
you end up at Saturday Night Live you're
22 yeah right yeah would you major in at
Harvard Russian literature of course you
do the opposite of comedy because you
can really tap into Russian literature
when it comes to humor okay I lived in
st. Petersburg for a summer in Russia I
used to speak pretty now Russia not
Florida of course you're talking yes
correct those st. Pete is a wonderful
city yes I don't want to you know to run
down st. Pete Florida but uh there's
probably some Russians there too right I
don't know yeah probably
they got mixed artistically yeah and
then they were really happy this is the
best I love the audition process for
Saturday Night Live because like I just
can't imagine going into that room
Lauren Michaels they're your
predecessors and you know those who
you're gonna be working with you know
here's Seth Meyers who leaves and all of
a sudden you're 22 and you walk in and
well I when I'm sorry I don't I started
as a writer
it was submitting a packet it was you
know when Tina Fey was the head writer
and Andrew Steele was the other head
writer and I submitted them so that's a
lot easier cuz you're not watching them
read it versus see I mean they didn't
laugh at something which I'm sure they
didn't I didn't have to hear that
silence echoing a room okay
but then and then when I when I did
screen tests for Weekend Update
that was really terrifying because it
was people I knew now as a writer and
then suddenly or like feel like you have
to prove yourself in a totally different
capacity to people that you and then you
feel like you're disappointing family if
it's not good you know I mean it's a
weird feeling well who do you ask for
advice you ask everyone you know I
emailed you know emailed Tina and Seth
and Jimmy and I asked my co-workers and
everyone has advice but when you're
starting out you don't know enough about
the job to even process the advice I
don't know if you ever felt that about
anything but like before you do it you
don't even know that vocabulary in a way
or you don't know the feeling of doing
it so now I should you know when I look
back if an advice they have now it makes
sense
but at the time you're just you're
you're overcome by nerves and you don't
know what the whole form but are you
watching it was there a newsman that you
watched too like a real yeah it's
interesting because it's a strange time
for that so like who you would look at
you know I mean it kind of it was Brian
Williams was probably the closest that I
would watch on a normal night ly news
night I mean there's still Dan Rather
was in my head probably the most as this
was my Newt that was my news guy that I
knew from growing up but there being
serious you're sort of being serious
yeah and there's a difference there
there's a difference you it's always
nice to have a starting point you know
to have a something that you're that
you're that you can base that you can
use as a foil in a way or start with
before you before you try to put comedy
on that but uh yeah it's weird cuz in my
area I would watch John Stewart you know
or I watched nor McDonald or Tina or you
know Amy and Jimmy and those guys as
much as I would watch regular news so I
didn't have as much the regular news
thing or I would think that one of the
toughest parts is to not crack up
because you're the news man yeah but you
have the performers there and they're
deep down they're probably saying if I
make you laugh I'm making everybody
laugh yeah so there's competition there
of let me see if Colin you know you know
laughs and I break him up a little bit
here
yeah and it's it's it's sometimes you
you do because there
really trying to make you and then and
certain people are good at surprising
you you know Bobby surprising me and
grabbing me or Leslie just getting right
am i screaming my face and that is
that's very surprising and that you like
that because it just makes you very
present in the moment it like jars you
into the real-life situation of you're
talking to another person out there not
just on TV in front of millions of
people did you do the right to skit on
David Ortiz big pop yeah yeah okay what
what is it about Big Papi did you say no
that can be funny well I guess I was
talking to Keenan about it I feel like
we originally tried it originally wrote
it as a judge show like a court a court
TV kind of like him hosting a People's
Court style thing
so he's Judge Judy yeah basically and he
would just give everyone like a whole
chicken and you know that would be the
settlement and like a chicken that was
cooked in a little in a trap you know
like a one of those barrels you see a
game and and that did not work
resounding failure at the table read but
his impression was so fine Kenan's
impression is so funny and he's like one
of the best people in the world to write
for cuz he's so he can get every laugh
but his he's just joyous as playing
ortiz and so then we tried it on update
and it worked but we had to do it for
another year almost and then the next
time it worked even more and then week
so we did it I think we've done it twice
this year but uh it's pretty cool and
and Ortiz actually sent me a video cuz
when it was I when I had been at the
show ten years as a writer I have a
friend that's a friend of his and and
emailed send me a video and he was I
sort of said like I was like I want to
do ball hit batting practice one time at
Fenway and I was like I think I really
if I got the right one I could hit a
ball out and he was like send me video
and he's like I heard you think you can
hear that hit it out of Fenway skinny
white boy once you come by try it out
and and he was like and congratulations
I haven't gone yet so I gotta I gotta
get you know in batting shape do you
really wanna do it think well you have
to get back you seem so skeptical I mean
everyone I'm very skeptical is it just
impossible
I couldn't how you don't think I could
do it hmm I think it's the Harvard thing
that holds you back
well people play baseball there I mean I
know but probably not that well but they
play baseball they're like if you said
you went to Alabama Florida State yeah
yeah well can I just say that no no you
have actually wore a sweater that's
Harvard oh well that's nice
this is your Christmas this is closer to
I don't know this is not gonna set in
Oaxaca this is only gonna dig the hole
deeper but it's more of a magenta I
think you were eggplant I think I wore
eggplant I think I might have stumbled
into wearing an eggplant that doesn't
scream homerun no no it does not
Collin is headlining Caroline's on
Broadway that'll be tonight through
Saturday for tickets go to Caroline's
comm what do you know you're funny
when people are laughing like what it's
kind of it like your family families you
see the toughest to crack yeah but
that's you don't care about your family
when you're young I mean I guess when
you're really young but once you're in
high school if you made your dad laugh
in high school you'd be like I think I
got my failure you know even though my
parents are funny you just that's not
what you're looking to do it's when you
make your classmates laugh when your
classmates are crying laughing or you're
crying laughing with you know about
stuff then you're like I'm in the
ballpark but are you there's a lot of
humor in growing up on Staten Island
yeah my wife is from Staten Island is
she really yeah yeah it's a fascinating
place but she got out which is good I I
freed her you freed her I got her off
the island Staten Island obviously you
know has a reputation in a way it's a
great place it's a great place to grow
up
it's like idyllic all parks I play all I
did was play sports growing up it was
like you have everything there but you
also have places like Great Kills like I
love that there's a place called Great
Kills Great Kills have good kills here
we have the best kills but there I
remember seeing houses mansions no
shrubbery at them at these mafia guys
houses because they didn't want anybody
be able to hide in a source so there's
no shrubbery outside of the houses there
was there were house you know I knew
where the house were like the real-life
Godfather lived I knew that there were
houses I passed the head glass broken
from bullet holes that was not repaired
for years they've just like
now and the house was there so you drive
by him like the one of the on the awning
at the front was glass and shattered by
a bullet and you knew that you know was
that was the the way of life you didn't
think did Gotti have a place out there I
don't know people it's crazy people used
to summer on Staten Island yeah people
from Manhattan in Brooklyn
there was a boardwalk a thriving beach
scene there's still some you know they
film Boardwalk Empire they used to film
Boardwalk Empire in parts of Staten
Island because it still had cottages
from when it was a beach town and you
did a movie on
yeah called Staten Island summer that's
on Netflix and it's we filmed at Great
Kills at the Swim Club where I grew up
swimming in my house my childhood home
which my parents will never allow anyone
to do again and and on my block it was
crazy all my relatives still live in my
block my parents live my grandparents
live next to my parents all my cousins
are there everyone was a fireman and we
went back and it was like fill it was
like a weird filming in your hometown
that's cool
did you were you there for the 40th
anniversary yes you hear Prince dies
yeah and I heard did you did you mr.
weekend update did you think did you
reflect back on that performance by
Prince the after party yeah it was
surreal oh it was like it was among cuz
that was impromptu by him impromptu no
one knew he was even at the party you
know and you knew people worth that's a
big room it's a big room but everyone in
the room you knew because you were there
either they work to the show or they
were Beyonce and jay-z and Rihanna and
and then Prince sort of they snuck him
up and it was like in now Prince and
you're like whoa and even people you
know I was talking to Adam Sandler when
it happened who's it's like me already
getting to talk to an idol of mine and
even he's like whoa print that was the
cool thing about the 40th was you talk
to people you'd be talking to Eddie
Murphy and you're like whoa and then
he'd turn and go Peyton Manning it was
so funny to see who people were excited
to see you know and or you know some you
know Giuliani's here yeah that was it
was the next person I thought of but I
was saying oh he said Manning Rianna
yeah those are pretty good yeah that's
not bad it is a good Prince Prince
dearly beloved yeah
and Eli Eli is still one of my favorite
hosts of all time because I mean I'm a
Giants fan but and he's given us two
titles which is about all you can really
ask for maybe even in a lifetime and and
you beat the Patriots and we'd be the
Patriots both times which is doubly
sweet you can see him at Caroline's you
can also see him on Saturday Night Live
co-host of The Weekend Update mr.
Harvard himself
Colin Chile's don't yeah so you can go
to Caroline I've learned that's the
worst intro in comedy maybe in history
like for an M for an MC MC when they
bring him out this guy went to Harvard
and now he's gonna try to make you laugh
yeah he's had everything in life handed
to him and down hey you take SATs you
know look at you look at you
McLovin it hurts doesn't it it really
does I wanted to go to Harvard and major
in Russian literature I mean if we want
to talk some Tolstoy later I'm available
I mean this is the one up one time I've
ever been offered that so I think I
should probably should say yes you can
see Colin tonight through Saturday for
tickets go to Caroline's calm thanks for
stopping by you ever have to have you
again thank you
all right how about tomorrow yeah call
me any time
now but later today yeah how about like
a 3:00 a.m. yeah want to come down the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience